hi I'm Anthony Burch I'm a writer
gearbox software I'm Steve Mandy Jones
I'm a gameplay designer 2k Australia and
we're here to show you
Nisha or Nisha depending on how you
pronounce her name I don't know I kind
of just looked it up online and this is
Borla as the pre-sequel and she was the
sheriff of lynchwood in Borderlands 2
she strangled bricks dog and killed
Alana is a people and she dated handsome
Jack and now she's a playable character
because we wanted to push the boundaries
of how heroic or not heroic a playable
character could be in a border landscape
who doesn't want to be a total bad guy
yeah a bad girl yeah it's fun to be a
bad bad a person so let's talk about our
action skills yeah so let's jump into it
so niches action skill is Showdown
basically showdown is short duration
action skilled turns her into a badass
gunslinger for the duration while it's
active she will automatically lock onto
enemies with her aiming and gets a whole
range of gun bonuses so damage fire rate
reload speed as we can see here it's
super cool you can use it just not with
normal aiming or if you go down to iron
sights you can sort of flick between
targets and just hit them in their
critical locations yeah so we'll jump
into a skill trees here first one we've
got is Lauren order this is sort of a
defensive melee based kind of skill tree
uses a stacking mechanic here called
order she generates these stacks as she
takes damage so she definitely wants to
be sort of up close in the fight with
this one because that buffs up the order
stacks which also sort of work with some
of their skills further down the tree as
well she likes pain yeah pretty much
this one's cool this skill is really
cool as well it's called wanted
basically as people damage her they get
these wanted stars above their head up
to five and if she then damages people
with wanted stars she consumes the stars
and does all this extra damage to them
so it's kind of like this revenge skill
it's a it's really fun and you can sort
of like if you're getting smashed up in
a fight it's sort of this visual
indicator as to who you should kill you
see people with five stars you know you
want to
them what's this one do this one just
sort of makes her order stacks even
stronger so whenever she gets about ten
stacks she gets all of these bonuses
that get even stronger as she makes more
stacks it's really strong skill that's a
whip she has what does a whip do if you
get the capstone of this yeah well Nisha
is a close-combat weapon is a whip as
you said which is really cool it's a
cool weapon just normally like it's got
longer range sounds cool it looks cool
and the capstone of this skill tree is a
mellow override that gives it this
cone-shaped shock burst of damage when
she does it and that damage is increased
by order stacks so like you want to get
in there start taking damage hitting
people and then when this builds up you
hit them with that and it just you know
will kill three four or five guys in one
go
neato what's this one about this is the
fan the MS skill tree so this is a
heavily gun based skill tree lots of
sort of high mobility fast shooting
short-range skills some some nice buffs
to show down in this one as well like
she can get the one just above this
ruthless here as she gets kills during
showdown she extends it so if you're
really killing tons of dudes that are
just rushing you you can have like these
really long TRO downs it's really cool
there's kill skill here called short
fuse does explosive damage while it's
active so you do more explosive damage
if you're close to the enemies so you
really want to be in their face blasting
them with you know pistols and stuff
like that um a pickpocket is cool as
well since you're sort of up close you
can you don't have to stop to reload you
literally run out of bullets hit them
with your whip and that steals some
bullets from them loads them into your
gun and you can keep going that doesn't
make sense
because games portal enter correct and
yeah we mentioned pistols because the
capstone of this skill tree is this one
one for each of you
which basically whenever she uses a
pistol she gets a copy of that pistol in
her other hand which is kind of Awesome
and this
really cool gun combos you can do there
but how is that different from guns
irking and Borderlands 2
well guns irking was an action skill and
you can only use it for whenever the
action skill was active but this is all
the time so if you've got a cool pistol
you can use two of it as much as you
want you can show down out of showdown
all the time that seems bananas what is
this about this is the ruffle woman
skill tree which as the name implies is
heavily rifle based so it's not rifles
upper rifles but it's not your
traditional sniping skill tree it
actually has a lot of bonuses to firing
from the hip so you can sort of be
running and gunning and your accuracy
isn't going to be terrible you can still
be recruiting people and headshotting
and doing fine without using iron sights
there's some cool skills as well like
it's not necessarily in an elemental
based tree so like this one hot lead if
you're not using an elemental gun your
crits will now ignite enemies so you're
sort of encouraged to use Jacob's guns
which obviously suit a lot of these
skills a lot and they're never elemental
so this skill obviously is a great
pickup if you're using those kind of
guns some cool skills like this one
which where if your bullets miss they
will ricochet off towards enemies so it
further offsets the need to use iron
sights and it again plays in with the
capstone here which is called the
Unforgiven which is super cool so your
bullets ricochet more and any enemies
that are damaged during showdown will
explode at the end of it you'll pull out
how little detonator and set them off so
somehow if anyone survives a showdown
they're then going to explode and
they're probably not going to survive
that because it does stupid damage Chris
you were going to pick one of these cap
stones which one Stephen which one do
you want to see uh the draw now let's
check out Lauren order I think right I
should have a look at the whip because
the whip is cool
so grab wanted so we got those wanted
stars going on lots of these nice Auto
buffs there's lots of skills in that
tree that gets stronger as she takes
damage so she's on low health she does
more damage she definitely wants to be
in the thick of the fight and yeah the
showdown extending one is great anything
to give us an idea of where we are in
the in this story for this one in the
story right now we are in a mission
called intelligences of the artificial
persuasion and we are going to find an
AI that will help us build a robot army
we have a bunch of constructor BOTS and
Steward bots and a bunch of boring ass
little manufacturer dudes on a space
station but they can't hurt anybody so
we're going to go find an AI that will
allow them to hurt people meet
that's the thunder crackdown and we can
see our rotor sex sort of building up
here exceeds up to ten down the bottom
of the screen now how does the thunder
crack down in fluo get affected by order
and effect order I think it's ten
percent extra damage per rotor sex they
say we didn't have many before so if we
can get another one off soon it's going
to be much stronger you should fire
again there you go
eight order stacks yes and whip somebody
with a little hurdle I notice sex will
be lost if you are sort of grow out of
combat but if it's in combat they'll say
Chris fairly successfully with ground
well we only show off your action scale
correct yeah we should definitely have a
look at that so here we are intro down
and he killed them literally so quickly
you didn't know what it did
it's okay the thing about order the this
showdown skill is that it only lasts six
seconds at its base duration but its
cooldown is only 16 seconds so it's
actually unlike Wilhelm's drones
something you want to use all of the
time yeah like it's so quick that you
know you just pop it as soon as you find
a few bad guys and you don't need to
worry about if you've wasted it or
anything like that
so you can see the crosshair is locking
on to them there and you've got all
these accuracy bonuses so you're pretty
much landing every shot
and we were too no skill as well I think
it's rough rider' where your slams do
more damage and every time you slam
every enemy it hits gives you five
orders suck so it's a great way to oh
you just got ten order section hitting
those yes so with the cup yeah she just
keeps slamming and then use your whip
yes everyone's knife to cut being thirty
it's a great way to you know get a good
oh here we go now now weapon Oh weird
Iceland's are so neat
and your whips back up and then straight
down just mixing your edges yep
one of my favorite things about showdown
is discovering all the gun options that
have interesting interactions with it
because because you can use it with any
gun and often I've come to realize that
the best choice is with it and not the
ones you would necessarily think you
know obviously like a Jacobs pistol or
something like that is really cool with
it because you just switch throw down
and you basically fan the hammer on your
controller you just mash the buttons as
quick as you can but there's some really
cool other stuff there as well like
burst fire sniper rifles for example you
might headshot three guys with a single
button press that laser gun he had was
very interesting is that a normal laser
gun yeah a tunic rub that one out again
he wants to trace that barrel there we
get it yes sir we have a legendary laser
gun here that it's a blaster type laser
which is one of our normal types when
you have a dial barrel but you see some
weird stuff going on here and you can
see the shots are actually homing in on
the target after he hits it which so
it's a legendary that is a bit of a tip
of the hat to a certain movie which I
think a lot of people will catch on too
if people haven't seen that movie then I
don't respect them and that's totally
fair Chris died so I don't respect him
that look so quick that's the most
unfortunate death I've ever seen yeah he
sure is very flexible
oh look at this what's going on here
story looks like story blazes little
story by users story lasers are going to
destroy Elvis and we need to use a lot
when he about story Lee what if a story
laser happened
that's that's really all it takes to
write a game that was a fool using
showing a little bit there are also some
really neat skills that Nisha has where
every kill you get will extends
showdowns length a little bit so you
will kill a guy and then kill another
guy and then all of a sudden get the
momentum you need to keep killing and
killing and killing and killing and then
it for you know you you know had turned
it a six second action seal into a
fifteen or twenty second action jail and
there's also another skill that
increases the damage you deal the longer
your intro down so if you've got both of
those skills going on it can just be
like sure down it's not going to end
until you've killed everyone in the room
oh yeah look exactly what we have going
on right here look at that it's
fulfilling right up with every kill and
there's no one left hook is that dude Oh
miss
you can sort of say the stars popping up
around the screen as well those are when
your discipline skill is active when
you're above 10 order stacks just to let
you know that you're getting all those
extra buffs
like all Cowboys Nisha is very good with
a submachine gun she's good with pretty
much every gun yep I'm really looking
forward to I think she's probably my
favorite haired I'm looking forward to
playing her with uh with pistols you
smashed that Luke Paul didn't even know
what hit it
air geyser it's a jump pad and a crack
all-in-one it's so convenient
um Chris could also give us a look at
how showdown works when you use iron
sights if if there's anyone left when it
comes back because you can use it in
normal mode or in iron sights and sort
of snap between enemies
see if I flicking the control stick in
ironsights mode he's going from person
to person at will basically so Jerry
it's very Clint Eastwood Bam Bam Bam she
three separate guys just a little [ __ ]
going on there it doesn't normally do
that but it's cool as well with the
flicking if you've got the rifle woman
capstone where any enemy damage during
showdown explodes at the end you can use
that to manually you know just flick
across everyone on the battlefield to
make sure they all get the explosion
triggered on them she says he heart
because she is a couple yep Anthony
donut just tell us a little bit about
the character dialogue in Borderlands
the pre-sequel and how that differs a
little bit from how it was in
Borderlands 2 that is an amazing
question Steven and I will not um so in
Indiana so I'm cool that's what defends
might one of them yeah so I am Borland's
to and in Borland's one the good player
characters basically just ciphers they
kind of just said it funny like we're
hopefully funny battle dialogue things
but never really had much to say about
the plot they were kind of just you know
gordon freeman types who ran around and
took quest from people we found from our
fans though that they really wanted to
hear more from the characters they
weren't playing these games as something
where they wanted to be totally immersed
and bleed they where the protagonist
they wanted to hear what their character
was saying because Borderlands is so
character centric as a universe so we do
a little bit of that work in DLC for
Borderlands to see okay we'll do they
like if they talk a little bit more and
people did so we fed okay well we could
maybe go further on this game and
actually have characters that are
constantly commenting on the plot so
when you get certain moments in the
story
handsome jack will treat you differently
depending on which character who you are
and your character respond differently
at depending on which character are so
because the things they have in the plot
some dark [ __ ] goes down and Athena
might feel a little bit more ly
ambiguous about it but Nietzsche is
going to be totally psyched because she
is a scary monster
claptrap was gonna maybe cry and want to
go home and when Jack talks to Wilhelm
he might be very very professional
because he's just a mercenary that he
hired when he talks to Nisha he might
try to get flirtatious because he has a
crush on their they're going to start
dating at some point spoilers for
Borderlands 2 for the sign question
Borderlands 2 though evidently less than
a fifth of our players finished because
optional content so yeah we have
jetpacks gabs
they are scary and they're armored as
well which means that there you'll one
aggressive gun if you can get it yeah if
you have one on I think since you're its
fire which is bad against crud metal
yeah if Frost for us the Frost is good
against pretty much everything it
doesn't have any inherent weaknesses it
does a little bit less to shield but it
does full damage against armor and flesh
but it gets its damage bonus when you
freeze someone because when you shatter
them you then get a bonus like it you
just creep that guy for ten thousand
while it was frozen exactly and because
you were inciting during showdown it
automatically locks onto the crit squad
yeah yeah so you just found a nice
little combo with cryo weapons and trow
down there so yeah this was just a
little bit of Borderlands the pre-sequel
with Nisha I'm Anthony Burch I'm Steve
Amanda Jones
[Music]